souvenez vous il est midi le 17 mars 2020 toutes
les radios et les télés du pays vous informe que
vous n'avez plus le droit de quitter votre
domicile vous est confiné confiné mercredi
confiné jeudi quand filet vendredi avec cette
désagréable impression de revivre encore et
encore le même jour comme dans un jour sans fin
où le jour de la marmotte peut-être avez-vous vu
cette irrésistible envie de communiquer avec vos
voisins vos amis votre famille peut-être certains
d'entre vous se sont demandés mais comment
je vais pouvoir continuer à m'approvisionner
comment je vais pouvoir continuer à envoyer mes
enfants à l'école ou même comment je vais pouvoir
tout simplement travailler ce jour là peut-être
que le monde a pris conscience que la lumière
était devenu aussi importante dans notre vie
collective que l'électricité ou l'eau que nous
buvons je parle de lumière mais de quelle lumière
cette lumière qui circulent dans les artères de
communication par lesquelles nous email nos photos
nos vidéos sont échangées entre nous dans le monde
entier cette lumière clignotante quand elle est
allumée c'est 1 1 quand elle est éteinte c'est
1 0 parce que toutes ces données sont numérisés
donc cette lumière va être émises dans une fibre
optique propagé dans une fibre optique comme
celle là une fibre optique ça ressemble à
un fil électrique pourtant c'est bien du verre
attention ça casse du verre transparent donc le
donc cet épisode a conduit à une adoption
accélérée des services numériques et la fibre
aujourd'hui si on regarde à quel point elle est
abondamment répartis dans le monde imaginait qu
on met bout à bout toutes les sections de fibres
qui ont été déployés sur sur terre qu'on en fasse
une énorme bobines et qu'on l'a déroule et bien
la fin de cette année pour la première fois on
dépassera la dernière planète connue du système
solaire cinq milliards de kilomètres de fibres
ça paraît extrêmement impressionnant et pourtant 3
milliards d'habitants sur terre n'ont pas d'accès
internet haut débit il ya peut y avoir de très
bonnes raisons peut-être parce qu'ils ont des
difficultés économiques ne peuvent pas se payer
un accès internet haut débit ou alors parce qu'ils
habitent dans un endroit isolé un désert une
montagne ou alors parce qu'ils ont été victimes
d'une catastrophe à beyrouth ou à saint martin
vésubie dans les idéaux dans les inondations
d'hier ou alors parce qu'ils sont sur un moyen de
transport un bateau un avion ou bien sûr avoir un
fil à la patte ça paraît pas très pratique pour
se déplacer certains d'entre vous diront que le
problème est connu il a été résolu depuis l'espace
par des satellites des satellites qui fonctionne
selon le même principe que nos téléphones
portables satellite qui utilise les ondes
radio eh bien il n'aurait que très partiellement
raison seul 1 % ou même moins de 1% des données
qui circulent dans le monde utilise les satellites
les données qui circulent d'un continent à l'autre
passe par des câbles à fibre optique sous marin
donc c'est que les solutions radio ne répond pas
aux problèmes dont je viens de parler imaginez un
monde où les satellites ne serait plus radio mais
optique après tout la lumière a transformé le
monde tel que nous le vivons via les réseaux de
télécoms pourquoi est-ce que la même révolution
n'aurait pas lieu dans l'espace pour ça je vais
m'interroger sur la nature même de la lumière en
comparant ces deux objets que vous connaissez bien
un pointeur laser et une lampe de poche les
deux ces deux sources de lumière ont l'air
très proches d'ailleurs elles sont basées sur le
même générateur de lumière qu'on appelle une diode
pourtant l'agent comportements très différents
donc d'abord une diode c'est un une lumière qui
va être émises dans toutes les directions c'est ce
que j'ai représenté là sur le graphe sous forme de
rayons lumineux qui se propage en ligne droite
imaginez maintenant que je mette cet iode dans
une boîte formé de deux miroirs en vis-à-vis les
rayons vont être émis dans toutes les directions
donc vont sortir de la boîte sauf s'il rencontre
un obstacle cet obstacle potentiellement c'est le
miroir sur lesquels ils vont rebondir comme dans
les jeux vidéo vous que vous connaissez bien et le
seul endroit où il y voir la possibilité pour la
lumière de faire des aller-retour sans s'arrêter
eh bien ça va être exactement sur l'acte formé
par les deux miroirs et si vous faites une toute
petite ouverture vous allez avoir en sortit un
faisceau extrêmement directif comme se pointer
évidemment pour le problème dont je parle
et c'est très intéressant parce que les
scientifiques connaissent depuis très longtemps
des lois fondamentales qui nous permettent
d'évaluer jusqu'où on peut aller entre les
ondes radio et les ondes optique et c'est
cette loi s'appelle la loi de la diffraction et
par cette loi on peut prédire qu'à un pointeur
laser et huit mille fois plus directif qu'une
onde radio la mieux optimisé possible ça veut
dire que ce qui va arriver sur terre sur la
surface que sur laquelle vous avez pointé avec
votre pointeur vous allez être 50 millions
de fois plus puissant sur cette surface ça
paraît un gain très intéressant et pourtant
il ya encore beaucoup de travail alors pour
simplifier le problème on va commencer par
imaginer que le pointeur il va être émis à
partir d'une position ce serait quand même plus
facile que cette position soit fixe parce que
quand j'essaie de stabiliser un pointeur avec mon
poignet c'est très compliqué donc imaginer ce qui
se passe si vous êtes depuis l'espace donc avoir
un pointeur qui se déplace à la même vitesse que
la terre pour donner l'impression qu'elle est
immobile c'est quand même très très intéressant
c'est un problème extrêmement bien connu par
les astronomes il suffit de se placer sur le
plan de l'équateur à trente six mille kilomètres
on appelle ça un orbite une orbite géostationnaire
mais 36 kg 38 km c'est loin et si on voulait
à partir de cette distance récupérer un seul
photon est bien il faudrait en émettre 100
milliards de milliards de milliards alors
ça peut ressembler à un problème d'extraction
d'une aiguille dans une botte de foin donc je
me suis posé la question quelle était la botte de
foin qui représenterait la difficulté du problème
c'est évidemment pas la taille d'une baignoire
c'est pas la taille du stade de france si vous
faisiez une botte de foin qui occupe la totalité
de la terre eh bien ça suffirait encore pas pour
représenter la difficulté de ce problème là donc
clairement il faut se préoccuper comment faire
une lumière puissante et alors là si jamais un
microscope extrêmement fin et que j'ai essayé
d'analyser la lumière bien je me rendrai compte
que c'est une vague une vague une ode à un donc
un un objet qui oscille et lorsqu'on essaie
d'imaginer qu'on ajoute des ondes et bien ses
ondes si on ne fait pas attention vont s'ajouter
de manière totalement désordonnée elles vont
s'ajouter on dit techniquement de même de manière
incohérente en revanche si je fais très attention
quel s'encastre rigoureusement l'une dans l'autre
camp je les ajoute est bien là je vais avoir la
possibilité d'avoir une langue dont l'amplitude
augmente augmente augmente et c'est ce que je vais
retrouver dans mon laser en effet lorsque je mets
mes deux miroirs en fait qu'est ce que je fais je
repli maisonde et donc j'ai toutes les conditions
pour les ajouté et si j'ai bien fait mon travail
alors j'obtiens exactement les conditions dont
je vous ai parlé auparavant il ya une conséquence
à sa place et qu'il faut que la périodicité
de l'undd toutes les ondes qui s'ajoute soit
rigoureusement identique or je vous ai dit au
départ que m'ont même à diodes et les mettez
une lumière blanche blanche c'est pas une couleur
blanche c'est la somme de toutes les couleurs et
qu'est ce qui fait que mon oscillations changement
de périodicité c'est justement la couleur donc je
prends la lumière qui vient de ma diodes et que
j'essaye de l'est de la ajouté eh bien je ne peux
pas arriver à cette condition d'encastrement
si jolie que je vous ai présenté juste avant
la conséquence c'est que lorsque ben à diodes et
mais à l'intérieur de ma boîte bien certes elle
aimait toutes les couleurs mais finalement seul
une va être capable de remplir la condition qui
permet d'avoir exactement les encastrement lorsque
je fais des allers-retours toutes les autres vont
s'affaiblir et finalement il n'en restera qu'une
une couleur très pur c'est intéressant lorsqu'on
veut faire un système de télécoms parce que à
chaque couleur je vais pouvoir associer un train
de donner et pourquoi pas employé sans couleur
simultanément qui vont transporter les données
de 100 personnes cent fois plus d'utilisateurs
donc mais une fois que j'écris un faisceau avec
sans couleur il faut que j'arrive à extraire la
couleur qui m'intéresse ça tombe bien la fameuse
boîte si j'ai choisi la bonne taille de la boîte
je vais pouvoir extraire une couleur verte rouge
bleu exactement simplement en changeant la taille
de la boîte parce que c'est la taille de la boîte
qui détermine les oscillations qui vont être
raisonnante à l'intérieur et qui vont pouvoir
sortir donc la cavité permet aussi d'extraire
les couleurs de les filtrer comme un filtre
coloré donc au final j'ai quand même un objet
extrêmement intéressant j'ai un objet qui est
qui donne lumière très pure qui est très puissant
et qui est très directif pour le problème qui nous
occupe ça paraît idéal oui sauf que ça reste
de la lumière et s'il ya des astronomes dans
la salle on sait tous que quand on observe
une étoile eh bien on a de la sainte îles à
sion scintillation c'est le fait que l'atmosphère
bouge et elle agit sur la capacité de mon pointer
d'atterrir exactement à l'endroit que je suis en
train de viser donc il va falloir gérer ça tombe
bien on a à notre disposition les mêmes d'outils
que les autres les astronomes utilisent et on
sait aussi que lorsqu'on fait de l'observation
astronomique pas que s'il ya un nuage qui passe
dommage pour nous c'est pas le bon jour bah ce
sera pareil et vous en tant qu'utilisateur de
haut débit ça vous plaira pas d'avoir votre
connexion coupée parce qu'il ya un nuage qui
est en train de passer donc là la solution il
y en a pas trente six mille il faut simplement
pointer le pointeur ailleurs donc viser sur un
autre endroit où justement à la météo est plus
clémente et terminer le trajet avec une fibre
qui se retrouverait au sol oui mais si je suis
au sommet du mont blanc dans un coin isolé qui
est un nuage qui passe je fais comment et bien
c'est pour ça que la solution la plus réaliste
ce n'est pas un satellite formés et vague avec un
simple pointeur ce sera une combinaison entre un
satellite hybride radio et optique vous émettrez
à partir de votre smartphone vers un satellite
par ondes radio et ensuite le reste du trajet
sera fait par le pointeur et éventuellement une
fibre si jamais il ya un nuage qui vient de passer
donc je suis convaincu que le satellite optique
sera au satellite radio ce que la fibre était au
cap téléphonique avec la possibilité de gagner 10
à 100 fois plus de débit et d'utilisateurs que ce
qu'on fait aujourd'hui et peut-être un avantage
supplémentaire pour les astronomes amateurs c'est
que plus les satellites sont gros - ils sont
nombreux - ils viendront à vous un impact sur
la possibilité d astronomes de regarder les
étoiles et ça aussi c'est un avantage merci